各位观众,大家好。
短线交易,一直以来都是市场中极具吸引力的交易方式。
许多人希望透过短线交易迅速获利,然而,这条路并非想象中那么简单。
短线交易不仅需要精准的市场判断,还需要高度的纪律、风险管理与心理素质。
短时间内的决策失误,可能导致严重的亏损,甚至资金全数蒸发。
今天我们将基于拉里
威廉斯的经典著作
短线交易秘诀
深入探讨短线交易的核心原则与策略
帮助您提升交易胜率降低风险
我们将涵盖关键的交易技巧
包括市场趋势判断
资金管理
情绪控制
以及进出场策略
并解答短线交易者
最常遇到的关键问题
例如
短线交易是否真的能够实现稳定盈利
如何判断市场的最佳进出场时机
高杠杆交易的风险应该如何控制
趋势是朋友这句话的真正含义是什么
本期影片将以严谨且专业的角度
剖析短信交易的核心要点
适合所有希望提升交易水准的投资者观看
如果您希望在市场中站稳脚步
请记得订阅频道
开启通知
让我们一起学习并掌握更专业的交易技巧
现在让我们正式开始
短线交易的盈利挑战与本质
短线交易并非通往快速致富的捷径
与长线投资不同
短线交易受时间周期的影响
其盈利空间通常较为有限
交易周期越短
潜在的盈利空间就越小
短线交易者如同于时间赛跑
通常只有几个小时的时间来精准捕捉市场价格的细微波动以求获利
这种高强度的时间压力
要求交易者决策果断且准确
稍有迟疑或判断失误
可能导致利润流失
甚至本金受损
有人曾形象地比喻短线交易
交易的时间周期越短
能赚的钱就越少
为了弥补这一限制
一些短线交易者
选择高杠杆交易来放大盈利
然而高杠杆就像一把双刃剑
在放大利润的同时
也大幅增加了亏损风险
一旦市场走势与预期相反
杠杆效应将迅速放大亏损
甚至可能导致爆仓血本无归
因此
短线交易的风险回报率往往并不理想
交易者需要极高的警惕性和精准度
才能在这种高压环境下生存并获利
举个例子
假设在白银期货市场
一位交易者建立五手头寸
并持有一个月
最终获利五万美元
然而
如果希望在短短一天内获得同样的收益
就需要持有更大的仓位
而这同时也意味着更高的风险
在如此高杠杆模式下
市场的任何微小波动都可能导致巨大损失
趋势判断的重要性与方法
在金融市场中
准确判断市场趋势是短线交易成功的关键因素之一
没有趋势就没有利润
只有顺应市场趋势
才能提高交易成功的几率
逆市交易则如同逆水行舟
往往会遭受惨重损失
这就是为时摩有经验的交易者常说
趋势是一切获利的根本
那么如何有效地判断市场趋势呢
一种简单而实用的方法
是识别短期高点和低点
摆动点
当价格突破短期高点时
可能预示市场即将进入下跌趋势
而跌破短期低点则可能表明市场即将迎来上涨趋势
透过持续观察这些摆动点
并结合其他技术分析工具
交易者可以更清晰地掌握市场的脉搏
制定明智的交易策略
此外
中期趋势也不容忽视
因为它能提供更多的获利机会
例如
在2004年3月
利拓
Rio Tinto
股价形成了一个较低的中期高点
比前一个高点更低
显示市场可能处于下跌趋势
当时
一些交易者发现这一信号
选择在适当时机卖空
成功避开了后续的市场回调风险
这类趋势判断技巧
在短线交易中能够发挥至关重要的作用
在金融市场中
情绪往往是交易者最强大的敌人
恐惧与贪婪如同潜伏的猛兽
随时准备吞噬交易者的理智和判断力适度的敬畏之心能够让交易者在角色时更加谨慎但若过度恐惧则可能导致措施良机
适度的恐惧结合自信
能够帮助交易者保持清醒的头脑
避免盲目乐观或过度冒险
交易者应当学会正视恐惧
深入了解潜在风险
并制定周密的应对策略
而不是让情绪主导决策
同时也要警惕贪婪情绪的滋生
避免因过度追求利润而做出错误的交易判断
建立一套系统化的离场计划
能够有效规范交易行为
降低因情绪波动导致的错误操作
有些交易者在市场波动剧烈时
会陷入自我封闭的状态
对进场交易犹豫不决导致措施良机
这种现象与心理恐惧密切相关
需要有意识地克服
此外
有些交易者会受到外界干扰
如媒体报道或市场舆论的影响
而无法专注于交易本身
这就像钓鱼时
关注的应该是于上钩与否
而不是假耳的装饰是否漂亮
在市场交易中
重点应该放在交易本质
而非外部噪音
资金管理成功地基石于铁律
资金管理在交易中的地位至关重要
甚至超过了交易策略本身
良好的资金管理能确保即使交易技巧普通
交易者仍然能够在市场中生存并逐步获利
透过适当的风险控制
交易者可以有效降低单笔交易造成的财务损失
从而保持交易的稳定性
一种常见的资金管理策略是
将每次交易的风险控制在账户总额的一定比例内
例如可以将每次交易的最大亏损设置为账户总额的1%或2%
这样即使连续遭遇亏损
也不会对账户资金造成致命影响
举个例子
如果账户余额为10万美元
风险比例设为2%
而每份合约的最大亏损为500美元
则该交易者最多可参与四份合约
此外
保持足够的流动资金至关重要
如果一名交易者因为谋比交易信心十足
而加码仓位
忽视了风险管理
那么一旦市场走势与预期相反
资金将面临巨大损失
在赌场中
每位赌徒的最大下注金额
通常都有严格限制
这与交易风险管理的原则类似
一个优秀的交易者
也应该采用类似的方法来控制风险
耐心等待
交易时机的选择艺术
在充满诱惑与机会的金融市场中
耐心是一种难能可贵的品质
交易者不应该盲目进场
而应该学会等待合适的交易时机
这并不意味着被动官网
而是要专注于寻找胜算较高的交易机会
而不是试图预测市场的每一个波动
只有当市场条件对自己有利时
交易才更具优势
有经验的投机者往往被比喻为熟练的猎手
他们不会给予出击
而是耐心等待猎物进入最理想的射击范围
一旦机会成熟
他们便果断行动
确保自己的获利最大化
例如
有些成功的交易者
只会在市场条件
明显对自己有利时才会进场
并将这种方式视为作弊机会
也就是在机会绝对有利时
才选择出手
而不是无计划的频繁交易
这种策略
可以有效提升交易的成功率
同时减少不必要的风险暴露
攻击日形态
反转的信号与交易策略
攻击日形态是一种常见的价格行为模式
指的是市场价格在特定交易日突然发生大幅波动
形成显著的价格突破
当市场在连续多日的窄幅震荡后
突然出现价格飙升或暴跌时
这通常是市场即将发生变化的信号
例如某些上升趋势中的股票或期货市场
可能在窄幅整理10至15天后突破向上
但如果价格短时间内回落并跌破突破日的最低价
则这可能是一个假突破
市场可能会进一步下跌
这种现象被称为卖出陷阱
因为许多交易者在突破时经常
结果市场反向运行导致损失
有经验的市场分析者认为
市场的运行并不是由某个单独的操纵者控制
而是受到集体意识与情绪波动的驱动
这意味着交易者应该警惕市场情绪变化
并结合其他技术指标来验证攻击日的有效性避免在错误的时间点进场拥抱刺激而非被其吞噬许多优秀的投机者
拥有一个共同的特质
他们享受市场带来的刺激感
甚至主动寻找刺激
然而
这并不代表他们是冒险家
而是因为市场的不确定性
能够激发他们的洞察力
与决策能力
他们将这种挑战视为一种智慧的较量
而非单纯的感官刺激
然而拥抱刺激并不等于鲁莽形式
真正成功的交易者懂得在刺激与理性之间保持平衡
他们会谨慎评估风险
制定详细的交易计划
并确保每一次决策都在可控范围内
例如有些交易者认为
做别人不敢做的事
或者在市场恐慌时逆势操作
能带来极高的回报
然而他们不会盲目行动
而是基于市场数据和经验做出决策
确保风险可控
宽幅震荡日
短线交易者的机会
在某些特定交易日
市场价格可能会出现剧烈波动
形成所谓的宽幅震荡日
这种日子对短线交易者来说
既是挑战
也是绝佳的交易机会
宽幅震当日
通常发生在市场经过一段时间的横盘整理后
受到突发消息影响
导致市场短时间内产生剧烈波动
例如某些商品期货
如黄金、大豆、原油等
在经历一段窄幅整理后
可能在某一天内发生大幅波动
价格从日内高点跌至低点
再回升至接近收盘价的极端位置
短线交易者在这样的日子里
应该积极寻找交易机会
并且尽可能持仓至收盘
以把握住市场的关键波动
从而弥补平时窄幅震荡时
可能产生的损失
虽然市场的最高点和最低点
无法准确预测
但通过技术分析
交易者通常可以推测市场在这些波动日会收于极端价位附近
挨压形态是一种基于市场参与者过度情绪反应所形成的交易策略
当市场的开盘价低于前一日的最低价或高于前一日的最高价时
这可能代表市场短期内发生了情绪性变化
并可能出现趋势反转
例如
当市场在开盘时大幅低开
许多交易者可能会因为恐慌而抛售资产
但如果价格迅速回升并突破前一日的收盘价
这可能是一个强烈的买入信号
相反
当市场在开盘时大幅高开
但随后价格快速回落
这可能是市场鉴定的信号
挨压形态的关键在于
市场的短期波动往往是由情绪驱动的
因此交易者需要结合技术指标来确认
趋势是否真正发生反转
例如使用成交量
趋势线或其他支撑阻力位来验证这一形态的可靠性
从而提高交易的成功率
趋势是朋友
顺势而为的交易真谛
在金融市场中
有一句广为流传的格言
趋势是朋友
这句话强调了顺势交易的重要性
因为市场的主要趋势决定了交易的成败
试图预测市场的顶部和底部
往往会带来巨大的风险
而顺应趋势交易则能有效提高获胜的概率
例如
在下降趋势中
交易者选择卖出
往往比在上升趋势中
卖出更明智
许多成功的交易者
都倾向于顺着市场的方向骑马
而不是试图去逆势操作
他们深知
逆势交易所带来的风险
往往远远高于顺势交易
然而
顺势交易并不代表麻木跟风
交易者仍然需要分析
市场趋势的真实性与可持续性
并制定合理的交易策略
例如
利用移动平均线
支撑与阻力位等技术工具
来确认市场趋势的稳定性
从而减少错误决策的可能性
下面我们将讨论并解答
短线交易者最常遇到的关键问题
短线交易真的能赚大钱吗
短线交易的本质
决定了其盈利空间的限制
交易时间周期越短
潜在的盈利空间就越小
短线交易者通常只有几个小时的时间
来捕捉价格的大幅波动
以此实现盈利
这使得时间成为不利因素
此外
短线交易需要精确的入场和离场时机
几乎没有犯错的余地虽然可以通过持有较大的仓位来追求高额利润但这也带来了巨大的亏损风险导致风险回报率并不理想
如何判断市场趋势
判断市场趋势的一种方法是识别短期的高点与低点
当近期价格突破短期高点时
可能预示着趋势由上升转位下降
相反,若近期价格跌破短期低点
则可能表明虚实由下降转位上升
通过观察这些短期摆动点
交易者可以更准确地把握市场的走向
从而制定更明智的交易策略
在交易中,恐慌情绪应该如何把控?
在交易中
对市场和自身保持适度的畏惧是必要的
适度的恐惧与自信相结合
可以帮助交易者保持理智
做出更稳健的决策
然而
过度的恐惧则会阻碍行动
导致措施良机
因此
交易者需要在恐惧产生时正视它
充分了解潜在的风险
并制定应对策略
而不是让恐惧掌控交易决策
资金管理在交易中有多重要
资金管理在交易中的地位至关重要
甚至超过了交易系统本身
有效的资金管理能够带来稳定的财富增长
即使交易技巧一般
良好的资金管理也能帮助交易者在市场中生存
通过合理的资金管理
交易者可以有效控制风险
避免因单笔交易的巨大亏损而导致破产
从而提高交易的稳定性
选择合适的交易时机需要耐心等待
市场中存在许多潜在的作弊机会
交易者应该等到这些机会成熟后再行动
通过发现市场规律并结合其他有利因素
交易者可以大幅提升交易胜算
高明的投机者通常会耐心等待
直到实际成熟时才果断进场
因为此时的获利机会最大
什么是攻击日形态
如何利用它进行交易
攻击日形态指的是
市场价格在特定交易日
突然大幅上升或下降的情况
当收盘价低于前一交易日的最低价时
可能看似突破下降趋势
但实际上可能会反转上涨
这被称为攻击日买入结构
相反
当收盘价高于前一交易日的最高价时
可能看似突破上升趋势
但也可能会反转向下
这被称为攻击日卖出结构
交易者可以利用这种形态
在市场反转时
寻找入场机会
以提高交易成功率
高明的投机者如何对待刺激
真正优秀的投机者喜欢刺激
甚至会主动寻找刺激
他们将这种对刺激的追求
视为智慧的源泉
对他们而言
刺激并非单纯的感官体验
而是一种能够激发灵感和洞察力的关键因素
然而
这种刺激并不是盲目的冒险
而是在风险可控的范围内寻求市场机会
对于短线交易者而言
最有利可图的策略是在宽富震荡日中持有仓位置收盘
通过抓住重要的价格波动
可以弥补在窄幅震荡日中可能产生的损失
虽然无法精确预测正当日的最高点与最低点
但通常可以推测价格将收于极值附近
挨押形态在交易中是如何应用的
挨押形态基于市场参与者对消息或图表的过度情绪反应
以及快速反转的现象
当开盘价低于前一日最低价时
可能提示买入信号
相反当开盘价高于前一日最高价时
则可能提示卖出信号
这种形态反映了市场情绪的瞬间变化
为交易者提供了利用市场非理性行为的机会
但仍需结合其他技术指标进行判断
如何理解趋势是朋友这句话
趋势是朋友这句话强调了顺势交易的重要性
趋势是盈利的基础,没有趋势就难以获利。
交易者应该跟随市场的主要趋势,而不是试图预测市场的顶部与底部。
通过与趋势保持一致,交易者可以大幅提升胜率,降低交易风险,并增加获利的可能性。